mayotte célébrer avec quelques semaines
de décalage la journée de la femme sur
cette île française des comores à
dominante musulmane
les femmes ne se cache pas le visage
avec un voile mais avec un masque de
beauté pour se protéger du soleil
entre tradition et émancipation mères
soeurs épouses naguère vigiles toujours
vigilante leurs couleurs chatoiement des
ste mans au second plan d'une société
mahoraise endormi par 130 ans de
sécurité coloniale viril à mayotte les
femmes sont de tous les combats depuis
toujours chatouilleuse ou guérisseuse
masseuse ou sage-femme elles ont veillé
aujourd'hui elles sont infirmières
institutrice journalistes ou bien
chauffeur de taxi restauratrice
commerçantes ou chômeuse al'écoute de la
réalité de l'île
elle y répondent en actrice autonome du
développement local l'émancipation de la
femme passe d'abord par l'autobus et
l'autonomie ça veut dire que la femme
doit avoir un travail avoir un revenu et
avoir une indépendance financière
à mayotte les femmes ont acquis les
droit moderne que leur soeur d'europe et
d'amérique avec conquis mais les bois ni
de bambou est savent que c'est dans le
secret de leurs traditions qu'elles
puisent leur force leur identité leur
poids économique aussi en multipliant
les micro entreprises
elle tisse aujourd'hui la trame du tissu
économique de demain